Hello Mr. Zak Nik. It's Imman from
Afghanistan. I'm 15 years old and I'm a
Muslim. I have two questions. When does
salah become further for a person? Is it
the age of puberty or age of 10? Number
two, what should we do about missed
prayers? I unfortunately missed prayers
for years. Should we just repent or
cover it? And if I must cover it, how
many years should I cover? Because I
became adult in 14 and now I'm 15.
Should I cover just one year or 5 years?
The question posed by iman from
Afghanistan
is that at what age does it become fur
for a person to offer salah? Is it the
age of puberty or the age of 10? First
the name Imman is also of a girl also of
a boy. So I don't know whether the
question posed by the questioner is it a
male or is it a female? Is it a girl or
is it a boy? We know that you are 15
years old but we don't know whether
you're a girl or a boy because iman is a
word is a name used for a boy as well as
for a girl. But irrespect what it is the
correct age at which the salah becomes
fur is at the age of puberty and the age
of puberty differs
between different people between
different sex whether it's male or
female whether you're coming from a cold
country or a hot country whether you're
living in India or Afghanistan or USA it
differs if you're a girl the right age
is at puberty when you start having
menstrual cycle A girl can start having
menstrual cycle even normally it's
between the age of 13 14 sometime it can
be even 12 it can even be 10 I being a
doctor I'm aware that girls even at the
age of nine they start the menstrual
cycle so the day a girl starts having
menstrual cycle is the day she reaches
puberty and from that time it becomes on
her to offer salah and for a boy also so
the average age may be 13 14 sometime it
can to the age of 15 and since you said
that you reach puberty at the age of 14
so that from that time salah becomes fat
for you if you're a boy but naturally
from the time you start having pubic
hair and the signs of puberty comes that
is the time when salah becomes and for a
boy also it's similar it may be the age
of 14 can be 15 can be 13 it varies
between individual so as far as you are
concerned since you said that you reach
the age of puberty at the age of 14 then
your salah becomes fur from the age of
14 and he said that now your age of 15
so you missed your fur the salah for one
year not 5 years regarding a question
that should you cover up or should you
catch up or should you make up for the
fur the salah that you have missed for
the past one year or should you just
repent there are two opinions for this
there's one opinion which says that you
should make up for it and as many times
as you offer your fur or assura
At the same time you keep on offering an
additional for the time that you have
missed. This is one opinion. But the
more correct opinion is that if you have
missed the salah intentionally and
purposefully there is no experation. Our
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said mentioned in hadith of say
bkari in say Muslim that if a person
forgets to offer salah there's no
expectation and the moment he remembers
he should offer it another narration
says that if a person sleeps and doesn't
offer salah the moment he wakes up the
moment he remembers he should offer
there is no expiration for that the
moment he wakes up he should offer salah
so based on these and various say hadith
the prophet was very empant emphatic and
clear that if you forget if you miss
your salah because of forgetfulness or
because you're sleeping like faj salah
you you oversleep so there's no
expatiation for it and the moment you
remember it you should pray immediately
you should not wait till your next salah
is there immediately and Allah will not
hold responsible there's no sin on that
so the second opinion which is the
correct opinion of the scholars is that
If you miss it intentionally out of
laziness or saying okay I'll read after
after then the salah time is over or you
know it is far then you may only offer
once in a day or you may not offer at
all for many years. According to the
second opinion which is a more correct
opinion there is no expiration for the
salah that you have intentionally
missed. It is a major sin. It is a major
sin. So if you intentionally miss any
salah, it's a major sin. And the only
remedy for this is that you repent to
Allah subhana wa ta'ala. You ask for
forgiveness to Allah subhanaa tala. And
you repent and inshallah Allah will
forgive you and to compensate for that
which you have missed. There's no
experation. But the scholars say that
you can increase your salah. the sunnah
mocka the sunnah mock you increase that
and do more good deeds for example give
more charity give more of donation
so do more good deeds which will
compensate for the sins you have done
but you don't have to repeat the salah
you have missed and this is the more
correct and the authentic opinion which
was even followed by the second calif of
Islam that is Omarab may Allah be
pleased with him including his son
Abdomar and various Sahabas. So there
are various hadith that reaffirms that
for this it's a sin and there is no
compensation like you don't have to
repeat your salah it's a sin you have to
ask for forgiveness and this was a view
which was also there by ham may Allah
have mercy on him even by
even
shani all these scholars even by
contemporary scholars whether it be bbaz
nas almani all of them say that if you
miss your salah intentionally
then you don't have to repeat it. You
have to ask for forgiveness and do more
good deeds whether charity more of salah
more of the sunnah salah and this is the
correct opinion. Even those people who
say that you have to read they don't say
that once you read it is like you know
if you have forgotten and if you offer
your salah immediately will remember
there's no sin they don't say that if
you have missed and if you offer salah
there's no sin they say that it's a
major sin but if you read then your sin
becomes less but the more correct
opinion is what I gave earlier that you
don't have to repeat it because imagine
suppose you realize at the age of 50
that I should offer salah and the time
that you had to offer salah was when you
became an adult when you reach puberty
maybe at the age of 14 so now you say
for 36 years I did not offer salah now
if I have to read for all the 36 years
will I live that long so maybe you'll
say okay since I did not read salah for
36 years I will not read for the rest of
the life so logically also it doesn't
make sense you have to ask for
forgiveness inshallah I'll forgive you
you can read as many more sunnah salah
salah
and do other good deeds like extra
fasting and giving more charity. So this
opinion which is more authentic opinion.
So for you also you missed your salah
for one year because you you reach
puberty at the age of 14. But you don't
have to repeat those salah which you
missed for one year. Just see to it that
you increase your you offer your
mada offer your offer in the last oneird
of night
fast more give more charity inshallah
may Allah subhanaa tala forgive you and
may Allah's month increase in your
blessings hope that answers the